Vita I have a problem
what's that Martin
my cloud run service displays user
profiles and it takes a while to
assemble all the data for user profile
on the server I've tried caching data in
a global variable between requests but I
noticed that it's not always there for
the next request that's because on cloud
run you're not guaranteed to get the
same instance every time but we can make
things better by turning on session
Affinity let me show you how
[Music]
first of all let's turn on session
Affinity in your Cloud run service
click your Cloud run service
click edit and deploy new revision go to
the connections tab
and check the session affinity checkbox
then scroll to the bottom and click
deploy done now what did that checkbox
do will I say new item on my cloud bill
no no it's it's included it's just
another toggle
ah I see and what kind of apps is this
useful for well your use case is perfect
your caching user-specific data that
takes some time to generate the first
time
session Affinity will make your cache
more efficient because Cloud run tries
to Route requests from the same client
to the same container instance every
time that makes sense another example is
a game that uses websockets and you want
the player to connect to the same server
if the socket is disconnected because
you don't want to rebuild the entire
game state in memory and introduce lag
for the player got it session Affinity
lets me cache data on the instance
between requests
what about sessions many web Frameworks
like Express session or PHP Symphony
support server-side sessions and I've
used them for shopping carts and similar
in the past can I use session affinity
for these server-side sessions I'm glad
you asked because you absolutely
shouldn't Cloud run skills up and down
and that means it adds and removes
instances so the request can end up in a
different instance that doesn't have
your data think of this like a regular
cache your code will run faster if the
data is in the cache but it shouldn't
assume it's there
so how should I use server-side sessions
in Cloud run then
well most people like to use redis and
you did a video on that how to board
stateful web apps to Cloud run ah right
Dean had looked into how to implement
server-side sessions in Cloud run and we
shot that video based on her findings
I'll add a link to it in the show notes
oh by the way did you hear about this
new feature that we added to Cloud run
it makes it easier to create a memory
store instance and connect your Cloud
run service to it yeah I saw that in a
video from the cloud next conference so
back to session Affinity let's say I'm
not doing server-side sessions and I'm
only using session Affinity to help with
local caching
I could still use redis for that caching
right yes you can use Radice for caching
but if you can easily recreate your data
like you did with the user profiles it's
cheaper and simpler to cache data in
local memory instead of storing it in
memory store ah I see session Affinity
makes a cache with user-specific data
more efficient
but Vita I am a developer I want to know
how this works how does cloud run know
where to send each request yeah yeah I
can relate with that I also want to know
how things work so session Affinity is
implemented using cookies
that probably means I will have to
include this cookie when I make API
calls from my JavaScript web app right
well usually you don't need to worry
about that many client-side libraries
include cookies by default but if you
are using axias use with credentials
which will make axios send the cookies
ah thank you for showing me pizza and
thank you everyone for watching if you
have any questions for bits or me or
suggestions for future serverless topics
please enter them in the comments below
we read every single comment until next
time
[Music]